this was supposed to be a festive time
for the kaushik family they're sending
out invitations for their older son's
wedding next month but the sudden
passing of his aunt kamlesh devi days
after she contracted dengue means
celebrations will be muted
after she went on the ventilator the
doctor warned us that for dengue
patients like her there was only a 5
survival rate
even after the fever subsides there is a
risk of organ failure her treatment took
a financial toll on our family
india has reported more than 120 000
cases of dengue this year while punjab's
caseload has reached an all-time high
several other states have reported more
cases over the last few weeks compared
to the same time last year
in new delhi hospitals like this one are
converting other wards to cope with the
influx of patients
the city recorded 1100 cases last week
at par with the total case count in
october
at least 10 people have died there
the current situation of dengue is very
bad in delhi we are getting many cases
of fever almost 250 to 300 cases of
fever and out of that 70 to 80 percent
are dengue cases
experts blame the extended monsoon this
year and improved testing for the recent
uptick in cases change in rainfall
pattern coupled with rapid urbanization
could increase dengue season in india
and make it more deadly another issue is
that the
health system the various health state
health systems and overall the indian
health system is getting
stronger in terms of testing dengue
while some civic bodies have carried out
fogging and fumigation to arrest the
spread of dengue the central government
has dispatched public health experts to
several states to improve testing and
manage response
the low coverage 19 caseload in the
country has made it easier for the
underfunded healthcare system to address
the dengue outbreak even as the northern
state of uttar pradesh is seeing a surge
in cases of the zika virus experts say
cases of both diseases will start
declining in a couple of weeks as
temperatures continue to dip ahead of
winter pavnee mithal al jazeera new
delhi